a phrase we've all heard at some point
in the industry consider the player dumb
you have to make things crystal clear
for them blue tarps yellow tags and so
on this quote comes from julian eva a
level designer from arcane studios to
his credit julian went on to say i think
that's criminally wrong i'd be curious
to know if that thinking is as present
in the japanese industry he also makes
it clear these are his views alone and
shouldn't be linked to any particular
studio and he's also not saying every
studio falls into that trap julian
recently had a very interesting twitter
thread where he took a look at elden
ring and gave some of his observations
coming from a game developer i think
you'll find many of these pretty
interesting for anyone who's played
elden ring you'll know there's something
from software has figured out something
they've mastered like few other devs in
the industry today and it all starts
with trust julian notes that elden ring
players are deeply trusted and he feels
it's been a long time since western
culture took a step back from such basic
values especially in open worlds as of
may 11 2022 elden ring had sold more
than 13 million copies since its launch
earlier this year which makes it far and
away the best-selling title from
software has ever released with these
staggering numbers it leaves players
like me to wonder if this could be the
beginning of a shift in how western
developers look at some of their design
choices in games julian says he feels
like eldon ring assumes the player
adapts and craves to experiment ideas
thus embracing the fact of shaking off
the expectations from time to time by
playing a lot with affordance to
possibly ridiculous extents he shared
this screenshot along with that comment
you can see here that it shows a section
of the game with an area that appears to
lead somewhere but the possible pathway
is collapsed it's not a jump you can
make on foot and yet it looks like it
should be well within the range of your
loyal steed torrent but a horse scaling
the side of a tower this is precisely
the affordance to ridiculous extents
he's talking about and for me speaking
from a player's side of things that is
what makes elden ring's world shine not
only is it a vast open world to explore
it's filled with depth and layers that
aren't clear at the beginning of the
game or even much later in the game in
some cases there's an almost constant
feeling of wonder and curiosity any out
of place stone or small ledge could be a
hint at something to be discovered item
descriptions range from mundane and
seemingly insignificant to containing
crucial pieces of information and yet
this has to be an incredibly difficult
balance for developers to strike if the
secrets and answers are too difficult
players may grow frustrated and give up
and if they're too simple then
overcoming the challenge may not feel
rewarding to the player in elden ring
the world isn't served on a silver plate
julian writes no one is going to come to
you asking to do this or that you have
to commit to set your own goals to take
the initiative to make attempts to fail
for me it's overcoming these challenges
that often gives my greatest sense of
accomplishment in elden ring even if you
don't come away from a particularly
difficult area with a new favorite
weapon or even a huge amount of runes
you still come away feeling accomplished
and that the exploration was worth your
time he says this dynamic definitely
puts you in charge a sense of duty you
know you came that far by your own means
and all thanks to your own observation
not because you followed a bright marker
that told you to pass there or kill that
thing or press that button you are
trusted and yet this trust would mean
nothing if frum wasn't also supremely
confident in their ability to design
worlds and systems that are both
inherently intuitive and challenging at
the same time while some could certainly
mistake eldon ring's challenges or
secrets as intentionally obtuse julian
believes the biggest secrets are made as
such to encourage discussions and
provide opportunities for collaboration
with players through other means such as
social media or even the game's
multiplayer from software's trust in the
player and confidence in their ability
to execute also extends to the elden
ring multiplayer sure some players use
it as an opportunity to troll or mislead
but by and large you'll find elden ring
riddled with helpful comments and even
players dedicated to helping others
overcome some of the game's most
difficult encounters julian writes feels
like we've been paralyzed by the fear of
letting our players get frustrated or
lost for a minute or two and find the
solution by themselves we might have
been trapped at our own game making
things obvious and avoid any kind of
struggling from our players at all costs
and sure eldon ring will let you try
time and time again on the same boss
over and over even if you're way under
leveled even if you're missing a key
item that can make the fight much easier
and yes even if you're one of those
lunatics like me who refuses to summon
help but all the while these systems to
alleviate and overcome those pain points
are built right into the game sure you
can beat your head against the wall
until you get good or you can lean into
those other systems by learning how
different weapon types work and how some
are more effective against certain
bosses than others you can grind away in
the open world and upgrade your
character until they're overpowered or
even outright summon other players to
actively help you with the challenge and
that's just beginning to scratch the
surface of the options you have at your
disposal of course in a vast open world
the map is also of the utmost importance
julian had positive things to say about
that as well he notes that it's a great
tool to use for navigation and treasure
hunting nothing is told you've got to do
a tiny bit of interpretation on topology
then reach that thing you noticed again
you're trusted no one forced your eyes
on it in his opinion verbally and
textually hand-holding the player at all
times is diminishing what they're
actually capable of which includes
things like understanding by observation
intuitive experiments and attempts on
their own and perhaps most importantly
acceptance of possible failure along the
road to be clear this isn't to say that
all games should be designed in such a
way in fact quite the opposite julian
says players know what to expect from
playing games like eldon ring they know
what they signed up for that's why it's
hard to attempt this in the west we
don't foster the same things there's
definitely a place for games that
provide more guidance and a more relaxed
stress-free experience but perhaps the
need and desire for more games like
eldon ring is greater than many western
developers have previously believed but
even if that were true it's not an easy
path for developers after all elden ring
builds on the years of work from has
already done longtime fans of the dev
can see numerous elements from their
previous games that all come together to
create what i believe is truly a
masterpiece in elden ring as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon